c'est ici que se joue actuellement la
bataille de mario paul dans le complexe
sidérurgique et métallurgique has
offices talent construit en pleine ère
soviétique dans les années 30 et qui est
devenu avec le temps l'une des plus
grandes aciéries au monde ont décrit
l'endroit comme une ville dans la ville
ça a été construit aussi pour soutenir
même une guerre nucléaire alors il ya
une ville comme souterraines c'est là
que les derniers bataillons ukrainien
qui serait peut-être jusqu'à 2000
soldats sont concentrées changement de
stratégie pour vladimir poutine qui
avait prévu un assaut ses troupes vont
plutôt à siéger le secteur il évite les
militaires du craignait à déposer les
armes et leur promet la vie sauve je
suis content du match
jetez-vous sur une ligne à chaque sorte
de fiction les stratégies relativement
petit d'aujourd'hui s'est débarrassé
pour humain est un homme raisonnable
aussi que c'est fait partie des
principales accusations à l'encontre de
la russie qu'elle est très peu de
respect des villes ukrainiennes
le président ukrainien qui accueillait
aujourd'hui les premiers ministres
espagnol et d'anneaux à kiev nan mais
les forces russes contrôlent déjà une
grande partie de mario paul
sutton organes ans la situation est
difficile nous croyons qu'elle n'a pas
changé depuis hier comme vous le savez
plusieurs milliers de personnes sont
coincées des militaires et des civils
surtout des femmes et des enfants
à des milliers de kilomètres de là
washington annonce une nouvelle ronde
aide un demi milliard de dollars
américains en argent et du matériel
militaire supplémentaire
cette enveloppe de 800 millions de
dollars américains inclut des livraisons
supplémentaires de dizaines de pièces
d'artillerie lourde 144 milles au but et
des munitions difficile encore de savoir
combien de temps les forces d'ukrainiens
tiendront le coup à mario paul donc tout
ce drame là c'est la grande inconnue
jusqu'à quel point quelles sont les
réserves en terme de nourriture et
d'accès à l'eau en particulier et
pendant que les militaires d'ukrainiens
tiennent tête à l'armée de vladimir
poutine dans la deuxième ville en
importance du dombass le bilan humain
lui augmente des images satellite
montrent aurait une fosse commune
récemment creusées la société qui a
prises les images estime qu'on y verrait
environ 200 nouvelles tombent ici pascal
harrison julien radio canada montréal